las sucesiones que puedes encontrar van
cambiando con cierta regularidad es como
una encontrar sus sesiones como 6 12 18
24 y 30 en las que identificamos que se
va sumando de seis en seis pero pensemos
en una sucesión que no asume números
enteros sino que sumen decimales es
igual de sencilla sólo es cuestión de
poner atención si tenemos esta sucesión
de números van en los espacios
primero hay que fijarnos cómo va
aumentando o disminuyendo en este caso
se van sumando cuatro décimas porque de
3.4 a 3.8 hay 0.4 y 3.8 más 0.4 es igual
a 4.2
si hacemos esto que los demás números
notamos que siempre se suma 0.4
así que para el primer número faltante
colocaremos el resultado de la suma de
4.6 + 0.4 lo que nos da 5
para el último término será 5.8 + 0.4 y
obtenemos 6.2
si tenemos la serie de números 2.3 4.4
6.7 11.1 16.8 y nos piden el siguiente
número cuál sería aquí no tenemos una
cantidad fija que se aumente o disminuya
4.4 menos 2.3 es 2.1
6.7 menos 4.4 nos da 2.3 11.1 menos 6.7
es igual a 4.4 y 16.8 menos 11.1 nos da
6.7 y los resultados son los mismos
números de la sucesión quiere decir que
cada número se suma a la anterior para
obtener el siguiente así que tenemos que
sumarle 11.1 al 16.8 para saber qué
número sigue y eso nos da 27.9
qué bueno que pusimos atención este tipo
de sucesiones no tienen un patrón
definido de suma resta multiplicación o
división pueden ir aumentando de
diversas formas
otra sucesión interesante se da a partir
de multiplicaciones de números
conformados por unos deja te lo muestro
si multiplicamos 11 por 11 tenemos como
resultado 121 121 si multiplicamos 111
por 111
el resultado es 12 mil 321 o sea 123
21 bastante curioso cierto ahora cuánto
es mil 111 por mil 111 pues 12
21 sigamos multiplicando
cuando tenemos un número conformado por
51 y lo multiplicamos por sí mismo el
resultado está conformado por números
seguidos que ascienden hasta el 5 y
luego descienden hasta el 1 si seguimos
multiplicando de la misma manera
obtenemos esta sucesión bastante
simétrica y curiosa
por último veamos las sesiones
especiales formadas con figuras
geométricas la verdad se ven increíbles
empecemos con las sucesiones
triangulares estas se forman a partir de
triángulos hechos por puntos para el
primero solo tenemos un punto para el
segundo tenemos un triángulo con tres
puntos los cuales son los mínimos para
formarlo debajo de cada uno pongamos los
puntos que los conforman
para el primero es 1 y para el segundo
son 3
después haremos crecer nuestro triángulo
un punto por lado es decir que no tendrá
dos sino tres puntos por cada lado en
total está conformado por seis puntos
nuevamente agregamos un punto por cada
lado y tenemos 10 en total
y si agregamos otra vez un punto por
cada lado para tener 5 el triángulo está
conformado por 15 puntos
esta sucesión es especial porque no se
va incrementando cierto número muchas
veces sino que el número que se suma
también va aumentando
primero tenemos un punto
para tener el triángulo de tres puntos
es porque le agregamos dos para el
tercero agregamos tres luego cuatro y
después cinco el siguiente triángulo
tendría seis puntos más el que le sigue
siete y así sucesivamente el número que
se suma aumenta de uno en uno
visualmente es fácil identificar cómo es
la suma si ponemos los puntos de todos
los triángulos juntos y sólo vemos cómo
va aumentando uno de esos lados así
tendremos más claro que se va sumando
más dos más tres más cuatro más 56
otra sucesión especial se puede formar
con cuadrados vamos a seguir el mismo
principio que con los triángulos solo
que los puntos aumentan en cantidades
diferentes empecemos con un punto luego
aumentan 3 y tenemos 4 para el siguiente
se aumentan 5 y el total es 9
después es más 7 y tenemos 16
aquí los números que se van aumentando
van de dos en dos
primero sumamos tres
luego 5 después 7
seguirá el once
13 15 y así sucesivamente los cuadrados
que resultan tendrán 13 igual a 4 puntos
más 5 son nueve puntos más siete son 16
+9 25 más 11 tenemos 36 más 13 serán 49
y así podemos hacer que el cuadro de
puntos siga creciendo y creciendo
se ve increíble y es muy fácil de
construir una sucesión así también
existen con pentágonos intenta
dibujarlas y encontrar más números de
cada una de estas sesiones especiales
conformadas por números increíbles